welcome back located downtown the
cornish pasty company is rich in flavor
and also history thank you to cisco for
sponsoring this segment and for bringing
the owner john bender and manager
nicholas thomas and into into the
kitchen today welcome you guys thanks
man okay so what is a cornish pasty
so it's a traditional english uh
handheld meat pie that uh dates back to
like the mid 1200s
and it's from uh the southwest um part
of england so i was told too is this
true that miners would would use these
because it was easy to make
you have your dough you just put
anything inside this thing you close it
up you go down to the mines and you open
it up you get a hot meal ready to go
correct yeah like the the miners wives
would would make them they would uh wrap
them up could take them down there and
they could eat it they would stay warm
for a few hours so by the time they're
ready to eat them they'd be ready to go
ready to go and then you have the the
crimp on top and they would throw that
crimp away because of the all the like
so the poisoning
was kind of like a handle to eat it yeah
and then you would throw that away
so what you didn't poison yourself with
with your mind on your hands and
everything sure i've been your
restaurant many times uh and i love it i
love the the cuban one you have but you
have 40 different varieties what are
some of the ones you brought for us
today so
uh starting with the traditional one we
have the augie that's just going to be
your your standard meat and potatoes
what you would actually get if you were
in cornwall
and then we we took the concept and we
did many different things we have a
we have a cheeseburger one it's bacon
cheeseburger with mushrooms grilled
onions
we even have
french fries inside of it
we have a reuben uh with our house-made
sauerkraut
pastrami
swiss and corned beef and then we even
do a bunch of vegan ones and we have a
vegan cottage pie up there i noticed
yeah he said vegan and vegetarian
options on the menu yeah about a third
of our menu is is vegan or vegetarian
now this one i have here is is this is
this new to the menu because this is
your thanksgiving special this one used
to be a special but it was so popular we
run it year round now and that is uh
turkey stuffing and sweet potatoes i'm
going to get served with a side of
cranberry and our red wine gravy
should i pick it up with a handle
i'm going to take it hard yeah just pick
it yeah get it yeah
oh wow
wow
thank you
and then we have some uh
we have our pasta salad
and then also we have a
tandoori wings
with uh indian curry spices
and then our parliament wings with our
house-made wing sauce and blue cheese
let me tell you this if you were to
create fall and put it in food this is
fall right here this is delicious yeah
this is perfect perfect watch i can
envision myself eating one of these
watching a football game or something
it's perfect for uh for thanksgiving
watching some football yeah forget about
my mom
in the kitchen all afternoon just get
one of these and be good to go yeah you
can actually uh you can actually order
them par baked
where you take it home and you get
you get to cook it yourself you guys
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it and thank you to cisco for
sponsoring this segment cornish pasty
company located at east charleston in
maine call them at
702-862-4538 or
visit cornishpastycompany.com